marbles epic superhero crossover film
Avengers endgame is officially the gift
that keeps on giving even when it's
presents are pretty bleak the latest
vine comes when a particularly sharp
eyed end game viewer noticed that at a
certain point in the film Steve Rogers
can be spotted wearing an army uniform
with the name Rosco on the chest this
occurs when Steve and Tony Stark travel
back to the 1970s in hopes of getting
their hands on the space stone that's
needed to make their Infinity Gauntlet
work to find the stone and help reverse
Thanos his fateful snap cap and Iron Man
infiltrate an army base where cap
eventually lays eyes on his beloved
Peggy Carter and Tony shares a moment
with his late father Howard it seems
that in their effort to conceal their
identities at the base cap ended up
stealing a uniform from a grunt by the
name of Rosco for a brief period in the
Marvel Comics run a brave soul called
Rosco Simon's carry the Captain America
mantle after Steve Rogers abandoned the
persona to become the nomad Bo Rosco's
backstory the character was actually a
lifelong fan of Steve Rogers Captain
America after Steve dropped the title
Rosco stepped up to become the next
version of the First Avenger
surprisingly Rosco proved a more than
capable fighter eventually winning the
approval of Steve and his pal the Falcon
and even earning the right to wield
Captain America's near indestructible
shield
unfortunately Rosco's time as Captain
America was brief as the character was
eventually captured and brutally
murdered by Red Skull upon discovering
that Rosco wasn't the real Captain
America after he killed him
Red Skull left a cautionary message that
the same fate awaited any other fake
Captain America's as tragic as Rosco's
death was it proved the catalyst for
Steve to again pick up the shield and
bring down Red Skull once and for all it
appears that the Russo brothers may have
been so moved by Rosco story that they
felt compelled to acknowledge him in
Avengers endgame using his first name
for the surname on Steve suit plus since
Rosco's time is Captain America occurred
during a run published in the 1970s
seeing the character referenced in a 70
cent moment an endgame is sort of a
double Easter Egg as for the odds that
we'll ever get to see Rosco Simon's on
any kind of screen the answer lies in
what the future holds for the Captain
America moniker as fans will recall the
final moments of Avengers endgame saw
Steve Rogers traveling to various
moments in the past to return the
Infinity stones to the rightful places
in the timeline however Steve reappeared
as an old man was
silver hair a wedding ring on his left
hand and a gift to give Sam Wilson
otherwise known as the Falcon as Steve's
longtime pal Bucky Barnes looked on Sam
told Steve only thing bumming me out is
the fact I have to live in a world
without Captain America that's when
Steve told Sam to try on his silver red
and blue shield signaling the
transference of the Captain America
moniker bull Sam and Bucky have been
Captain America in the comics and the
two our top lining their very owns is
the Plus Series aptly entitled the
Falcon in the Winter Soldier which will
indeed pick up after Sam was handed to
Captain America mantle many Marvel fans
believe that the show will not only
feature Sam as cap but also Bucky is the
star-spangled Avenger given their comics
history it's confirmed that the Falcon
in the Winter Soldier includes yet
another character stylized this cap John
Walker aka u.s. agent a militaristic
version of Captain America deployed by
the US government the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier sounds like it's shaping
up to have quite a few Captain America
so there is a slim chance that Rosco
Simon's could be part of it
it seems most likely that if anything
he'll be mentioned in conversation
rather than seen in the flash or perhaps
the series will incorporate a character
inspired by Rosco a Captain America fan
who's killed by some hero hating villain
in any case Captain America's mantle
will live on in the MCU and so will the
memory of Rosco Simon thanks to the
sneaky end game Easter Egg check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you